due anni credo forse anche un po di fila
l'ultima volta che ho fatto google
myself che per chi non lo sapesse era
questa moda un tempo di cercare il
proprio nome su google e vedere e vedi
vedere la vagonata di straw che uscivano
fuori sky su google fa la prima parola
chi riesce non è facile ma è favignana
maledizione a favignana e cefali jazz
fave favismo che ovviamente la religione
che si è sviluppata quando ho aperto il
mio canale cerchiamo fa dj fabio george
ha sbagliato a scrivere mio padre sul
sole 24 ore
il sole 24 ore ha chiamato un mio padre
non fatemi domande non solo perché
l'hanno intervistato sul sole 24 ore ha
parlato di me cosa dirà mai mio padre su
di me quando la piccola poteva gioco
time per me maurice cruz che alla sua
madonna i siti dove ti partono le cose
devo prendere infatti anche se sto
facendo google myself non è neanche un
horror il papa ci raccontano di dover
nurr1 regole passioni e nostalgie poi
vabbè l'articolo parla di va dai numeri
che ho fatto
robe del genere e c'è una cosa
importante che andiamo a leggere insieme
il successo lo ha cambiato
domanda fatta mio padre mio padre
risponde davanti alla webcam è il solito
perla questa roba è finita sul sole 24
ore c'è mio padre mi ha dato del pirla
sul sole 24 ore grazie papà meraviglioso
quale figlio si può vantare di questa
cosa in realtà tutto questo quest'astio
trame mio padre nasce dal fatto che mio
padre pelato e invece i capelli celio
scrollando su lungo troviamo amazon.it
famigie i due punti abbigliamento apre
una parentesi troppo cuciranno le
magliette con il mio logo nuovo che fa
esserci dell'abbigliamento su fa vj se
non ho aperto il merchandising vediamo
chi è che lucra sulla mia persona
eccoci qua allora maglietta fa vj tv
italiani youtuber fa vj con la j
maiuscola già ti fa i soldi col mio nome
ma porca una vacca almeno metti la joy
giusta ma la cosa che volevo farvi
vedere che da una vita che vedo sta roba
è
non potevo non parlarne questo design
che vedete la maglietta tarocca anni fa
vj number one cioè quella che ai raduni
vedo più spesso ed è una maglietta super
tarocca cioè fatta veramente da dei
barboni però va beh la cosa che mi fa
ridere di questa cosa che fa veramente
troppo ridere è il logo che si sono
inventati po dj cazzeggio time che è una
una serie che ho tirato su ma poi non è
neanche più continuato quindi che cosa
perché se proprio sul greggio time dove
noi non ci fermiamo mai
ma cosa minchia vuol dire di noi non ci
fermiamo soffermo sulla sedia su sempre
fermo sulla sedia ogni in ogni bit
confermo che scrivi tu sei in volte lo è
non ci fermiamo reiver quello corre io
soffermo suonava anche le cover dato se
cerchi fa vj poi la roba che ti
consiglia amazon in base alle ricerche
e questo perché fa vj un campione di
self nickelodeon che fa vigili un
campione di videogame lo sappiamo tutti
ultimamente però è diventato anche un
campione di serre ma cosa vuol dire
adesso sta avendo un estate da urlo e lo
sta immortalando una serie di sel fi da
urlo ad esempio queste senti a los
angeles cerchi a parigi e londra questa
sì scemo a grazie ai più apparirci per
il vero che los angeles e la azzeccato
perché
sarà veramente proprio mai fatto a
riconoscere los angeles da questa foto e
parigi da dado c'è la big ben dietro va
beh il videogioco di fa vj per ps4
io vi farebbe cos'è sta roba grande pio
3d ottimo modo per fare clic ometto che
ci sarà anche voi che rincoglionito e
nei commenti si sarà indignato credendo
che fosse vero spero non sia serio su
video perché se esce quel gioco la ps4
fallisce come consorte avete capito
quando vi dico che che gli haters che
dico che mi fanno anno 12 anni era
tagliata sanno sette anni come fai ad
essere una anche solo un ragazzo ma
essere così rincoglionito la scheda una
cosa del genere come fai a credere che
sia vero c'è mappa cosa insieme anzi a
colazione i tuoi stessi neuroni questo
120 è ancora più ridicolizzante per loro
news da youtube domande frequenti c'è la
mia foto di millenni fa però immagino
sia un articolo vecchio
leggiamo è un raccomandato no non è
entrato a far parte del look della luca
casadei management era già famosissimo
il suo successo se l'è procurato da solo
mi spiego quando io ho iniziato ad avere
successo su youtube pensava magari
alcuni non la sanno neanche troppe
persone che non riuscivano a piacere per
l'inter penso di no quando ho iniziato a
fare video c'era un sacco di gente che
non riusciva a capire perché avessi così
tanto successo e illudeva talmente tanto
il fegato che si erano inventati delle
robe che tipo review manager ritrovava
gli iscritti non si sa con quale magia
era ed era veramente convinti di sta
roba di microfono usa fa vj origine di
zambla yeti ottimo microfono leggete blu
yeti qua io leggo rote prode non 2000 di
erode come il culo degli haters fa vj e
ricco quanto guadagna e gay che monto i
suoi video parigi è morto quando è nato
clicca mi piace sotterrare risposte che
cerchi assolutamente e non me lo fa
cliccare ci sarà un motivo
9 questa crisi è fantastica protestiamo
fa vj letizia fantastico segrete che i
video di famiglie siano un'offesa alla
comunità di youtube e in generale alla
logica l'intelligenza sede
questo giusto ma secondo voi a questo
brucia al culo o meglio e mi ha fatto sì
un fenomeno mediatico tutto questo
offende inferi youtubers che ogni che
giorno e notte si fanno il culo
presentarci dei bei video arriva famigia
che un suo video decerebrato e fa un
sacco di views inaccettabile bastardo fa
vigente unitevi anche voi se troviamo
mille firmatari chiederemo direttamente
chiederemo di atleta felice di andarsene
da youtube
avrei mosso tutto il web con questa cosa
incredibile
però è un inizio questa ha detto che non
esiste neanche più il ciso nei commenti
si abbassa fa vj questa cosa qua che non
posso leggere perché sennò non è family
friendly deve andarsene a fare in
quell'altro family friendly
protestiamo farli gay e se si raggiunge
il numero necessario e non se ne va
no no no se raggiungere i 5.000 yo yo yo
me ne andavo a zero cioè non potevo fare
nient'altro cioè eravate ovviamente in
maggioranza non potevo dire niente rosea
restare solo zitto e che poi molta gente
vedo che in questi casi mi difende del
tipo ma se non ti piace il world dal
romani che cosa significa sta frase non
credo che qualcuno 1 menta con le
cinghie sulla sedia possiamo guardare i
miei video che credo che lo sappia bene
che se una cosa non gli piace con non
guardarla non glielo dite non serve a
niente e loro li brucia il culo e quindi
devono in qualche modo sfogarsi così
scrive di ragazzi io posso concludere
qui ci sono tante cagate sul web ma ci
divertiamo anche per questo meno capita
vi sia piaciuto penso di poter
concludere qui se riesco a trovare il
mio maledetto telecomando e piccola
sostanza come faccia perderlo
io non ho parole una ragazza cieca
impossibile senza doversi iscrivere ci
vediamo il prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]